many americans are getting ready to
travel for the 4th of july
aaa estimates almost 48 million
americans will drive or travel more than
50 miles from home between now and
monday if you're flying sorry to tell
you you may not get there on time an
average of nearly 700 flights a day in
the u.s have been canceled over the past
week as airlines struggle with too many
passengers and not enough workers errol
barnett is at washington's reagan
national airport errol good morning how
can passengers prepare for this
hey there look good morning and good
luck if you're flying be prepared for
airports to be packed just like this and
now more than ever you really should
have a plan in place right now should
your flight be cancelled we're watching
the volume of air travelers approach
pre-pandemic levels the tsa tallying
more than two million flyers almost
every day in june and over the past two
days we've seen about 1200 flight
cancellations with delta and united
reducing their summer schedule starting
tomorrow now these mass cancellations
are gaining attention on capitol hill
senator bernie sanders now calling for
airlines to be fined 55 000 per
passenger for a flight and airline knows
it cannot willingly staff now we'll see
if that gains traction but you should
know your rights generally speaking
airlines are required to offer refunds
if they cancel your flight and you
refuse an alternate one or if there is a
significant delay but definitions of
that phrase do vary and you're eligible
so long as you're not on one of those
non-refundable tickets of course and if
your flight is canceled at the beginning
of your trip you're on the hook for any
portions you pre-paid that's if you
don't have flight insurance so certainly
get those protections and be as flexible
as possible because vlad air travel
these days truly is for the brave
errol thank you very much